[Music]
in killer Klown news no no submit it by
McCain by beginning badass when you get
the chicken sandwich and a hamburger and
you [ __ ] it together right what is it a
it's a big match you shake it McNuggets
really you know it's a it's a chicken
sandwich okay yeah you could google it
pops up no that's when you get a Big Mac
and you stick it in between your dick
and [ __ ] it yeah that's amazing
a woman was arrested in a 27 year old
cold case when authorities figured out
she was the one who killed her now
husband's deceased wife she was dressing
as a clown and did it yeah can you
imagine getting away with murder for 27
years and then all isn't it haunts you
what's crazier is your new wife is the
killer of your old wife yeah I'm cool
with that
damn she wanted a dead girlfriend and
you told me hey just let you know I
killed that [ __ ] I'd be like oh cool
because you're my current one her love
replaced the old one yeah but you
wouldn't be worried that she might like
[ __ ] flip a switch and kill you no
because she killed her for me how do you
it's very romantic she like she loved
him so much she killed them he killed
like she had to be the one that that is
yeah it makes sense
I forgot sorry it was just like we did
hey hey remember that girl killed her
you remember that girl you were dating
in college and how she just disappeared
she didn't leave you I killed her you
gonna get a boner from that I wouldn't
get a boner but I'd be okay with it
oh good but what if that person's me and
someone kills me what the [ __ ] well you
wouldn't bill to nag at me
so you wouldn't be able to be like I
can't believe it for that [ __ ]
and I blow your butt saw that guy come
out of me what the [ __ ] but do you get
mad at the 2017 Honda Accord when it
replaces the 2015 on the close the
[ __ ] Honda Accord let you fart in the
same room as them from now on didn't
push out your kid did it marry your ass
this is a time when you're supposed to
make her feel special thank you you're
becoming a Meg do you want to feel like
it's impossible to be with nobody
yeah I do mean but that's why you're the
one that came up with this evil
hypothetical I was saying if you feel
yeah if you killed my you killed my
grandma high school girlfriend I was
cool with it and then you're like but
then what is like if the tables were
turned and someone came and kill me I'm
a that was it even example I brought up
you bought that one she has one button
right here like I like the flannel with
the one button yes that's what I was
taking a [ __ ] and I was like can I dress
Tycho's I told her for hallways you said
yes baby Cortez's and then you guys did
the cholo [ __ ] oh you know Halloween yes
I said it's okay you just recycle that
that's but what I was saying is you flip
the script on it just stop saying in my
romantic example you're the killer
anyway right now you want to be the
killer
they killed killed
[Laughter]
anyway sorry this took place in Florida
back in May of 1990
Sheila [ __ ] that was a long time ago
yeah
[ __ ] yeah Sheila who is the killer she
dressed up as a clown joke gosh to her
victims home shot her point-blank in her
head with her with the victims 22 year
old son witnessing all this and then
family members what something at all
because a psychopathic [ __ ] Heine
yeah [ __ ] she didn't marry the widower
until 12 years later so it's still not
clear if the husband even knew about it
or if she even knew the husband or like
it's a coincidence we don't know her
motive as of yet but what did the
husband like during their date talk
about like so my wife died and this lady
in a clown outfit came in shot her and
she's like oh really
that'd be crazy yeah like she's gotta
know that's true she's been with them
for 27 years like she's got it
no yeah so for sure she must know that
but what I'm saying is like it's not
clear if the new wife and the widower
even knew each other at that time
because they got married 12 years later
so we don't know it's not it's not
really clear so then as of now they're
saying that the detectives haven't said
whether or not Michael the widower was
involved in the murder no it's just like
we don't know like I don't even know how
they ended up meeting or marrying each
other after his wife died that'll be
crazy if they didn't know each other and
and it just so happens that they were at
the roller rink and then they met up
somehow and fell for each other and then
later he found out or unless she found
out but she kept it to herself yeah cuz
I'm thinking there's a possibility where
it's like it's a small town and everyone
yeah and then she just hated the wife or
whatever because she always baked the
best [ __ ] and got all the attention or
whatever but yeah she killed Marlene
and so it was a mystery it was a cold
case for the longest time until back in
2014 the detectives I opened this they
reopened the case and they conducted a
mewed and water they why do they real oh
because of DNA technology yeah so DNA
technology advanced and so they were
able to run a new analysis and they
discovered that Sheila was linked to the
murder they're doing that a lot these
days
yeah can't trust no females no you can't
trust clowns that's looks like a clown
Sheila
Marlene died looks like Marlene dad big
nose like a clown she doesn't even look
like a killer I know she looks nice and
I was wondering to like have like a more
recent photo like in 1990 I just look
like her when she was younger yeah yeah
yeah like usually when when there's a
killer and you show us a picture I can
tell by the face eyebrows all [ __ ] up
we got forehead high or like but in this
case I don't see the killer she looks
like a kindergarten teacher there must
be some darkness in the eyes now it is
pretty dark I really want to know her
motive like whether she was like out
just towards the victim or like how she
was madly in love with her husband but
just could never say it I just try to
get her out of the way did she ever
explain herself now know that she's
caught like this is the reason why he'll
know I hate these unfinished [ __ ]
stories mm they drive me crazy that's a
[ __ ] up way to go though shot in the
head by a clown oh well this be better
if it's a different outfit just like
just one scarecrow oh that's fine Jake
um a burglar or something like a ninja
maybe why a clown you know like clowns
already have a bad rep so like let's
just back off of the clown's
the dish's clown shaming a little bit a
little bit you're just you're just
sympathizing for the clown organization
cuz they already got a bad rap
you don't want them to have more bad PR
and and then it is all like the talk of
the town there's too much discrimination
going on right now with clown lady all
this clown mongering like clown
fear-mongering and like everyone's gonna
just start like hating clowns for no
reason they can't get jobs you know they
won't be able to vote all this stuff
after finding out what did the husband
say I mean damn it
yeah maybe she put a lot of living
together in Tennessee so they had to
extradite her to Florida oh it happened
in the pill already that's weird it's a
totally different states with me I'll
say maybe she put a lot of thought into
what she was gonna be because you own
the 90s clowns were very popular I know
my mom showed up to pick me up from
school a dressed as a clown and I
freaked out [ __ ] does she hate you she's
a preschool teacher so she was your mom
yeah she was trying to like dress up and
her just scary all the kids work it oh
yeah I remember that in elementary
school and like Halloween des was always
a teacher that did some you know
hardcore clown stuff I remember I was so
embarrassed and she picked me up I was
like oh my god mom help could you do
this to me I think I was like in fourth
grade or something or it's like you know
really yeah and she was like oh she's
just being really sweet and then all my
friends the next day were like who was
that who picked you up in a clown
costume that was so cool and I was like
no it was my mom and then I get it slip
but I was just like kids you know I
think from third to fifth grade
everything that my parents did was so
embarrassing just having them stand next
to me was embarrassing doing anything
they're breathing and I'm just like I
[ __ ] hate your presence man like I
feel like people are gonna laugh at me I
know what you mean because then I saw it
and Isaac maybe like mom like his first
day of school for fourth grade
like no you're starting that was that
different from Thursday you still like
me right no you should not shut up you
little [ __ ] [ __ ] cooler than all
these [ __ ] fat [ __ ] you don't even
know we're back to fourth yeah fourth
grade is like when you really start
caring about you want to be more junior
high or the adult life it's like all the
cool kids were the kids that were
neglected that's true it's like oh I
wish my parents didn't [ __ ] care
about me dude I want to be that [ __ ]
rebel did your mom make you lunch
[ __ ] loser yeah you're fair your
pears there to pick you up again man you
have to [ __ ] walk home you're so
[ __ ] cool dude [ __ ] you wanted them
to pick you up in a ghetto car not the
nice cars really know my dad think
they're gonna get okay I had a pickup so
I wanna be [ __ ] normal yeah you
always had a pickup truck and I'm like
just pick me up why did your dad have a
pickup truck you always like trucks
Oh like you always always had a truck
that was manual Oh cuz my dad always had
it and I hated it but that's cuz that's
just his line of work no I didn't even
need one he's a dealer out of casino but
he always had a truck I i hella ditched
my grandma when she came to pick me up
like well I live two blocks away and I
think that day she was just taking a
walk and you know decided to just she
wanted to see me but as soon as I saw
her I freaking hid and I just booked it
the other way and I ran back home
she didn't see me she's like where away
I thought you know I was waiting for you
and all the kids were all you [ __ ] but
I thought you [ __ ] I picture her all
night
she's all I know now I feel bad cuz I
mean you know like if she were here
today I would be like yeah grandma's
here they will talk about school and
[ __ ] but like fourth grade fifth grade
though it's like no no one cares about
me you know you want to run away from
that I don't know why cuz you're dumb
yeah hey guys thanks for watching that
last episode did you love it yes you did
so don't forget to subscribe if this the
first time you're here we've upload
every single day so don't miss an upload
now to watch more episodes check them
out up here
[Music]